vers qui les 6000 électeurs trappistes
de jean luc mélenchon se tourneront
second tour le 10 avril dernier la ville
a vu le candidat la france insoumise
arrivé en tête avec 60% des suffrages ce
mercredi matin sur le marché les
trappistes sont partagés il disait
toujours je pense pas que je vais voter
parce que je vais pas inventer une lime
à crosne et les pnj au milieu mais je
vais réfléchir monsieur macro nous à
promet plein de choses mais
malheureusement là
on a comment dieu n'a rien on a rien qui
a été fait pour pour l'instant on va
essayer de voter deuxième tour
espérant bien qu'il va et va tenir ses
promesses pour le second tour je compte
par voter pour moi est ce que macro
n'est pas plus pire que marine le pen
j'en viens à me poser cette question
donc du coup
je ça semble franchement ça me choque
pas du tout que mc oui pour repasser une
deuxième fois parce que je pense que ces
cinq années qu'on a vécu sous son mandat
sincèrement c'était la catastrophe et
sincèrement je me dis pourquoi pas
marine le pen alors dans ces cas là pour
certains électeurs le regard est déjà
tourné vers les prochains scrutins les
élections législatives des 12 et 19 juin
prochains on aimerait qu après les
législatives les députés apparaissent au
mois de juin que mélenchon très la
france a soumis prennent une place
prépondérante pour aider les gens au
niveau du social on a un objectif
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir à l'assemblée
nationale un groupe qui soit et combatif
comme il l'a été avec 16 députés mais
cette fois ci avec l'avantagé du nombre
et une capacité de blocage c'est ça que
nous cherchons à avoir aujourd'hui une
cohabitation jean luc mélenchon a aussi
réalisé un bon score dans les villes
populaires comme mantes-la-jolie manque
la vie sartrouville chanteloup les
vignes ont encore la verrière dès le 10
avril la france est soumise n'a pas
appelé à voter pour emmanuel macro mais
a souhaité qu'aucune voile naya marine
le pen